one of the best stories in all of sports
is the Las Vegas Golden Knights an
expansion team that is already the most
successful expansion franchise in sports
history not just NHL but sports history
and then the ride keeps going the
general manage that team is George
McPhee he joins us here on the Dan
Patrick show just like he drew it up
right George
we weren't expecting we we wanted to be
good we wanted to be competitive but
this is certainly beyond what we could
have hoped for okay so when you're
drafting an expansion team and putting
together a roster I mean what are the
core things that you're looking for and
and what are your expectations
realistically in that first year well we
had two objectives going into the
expansion draft and that was to get a
team that could compete because it was
important to the NHL important to the
Las Vegas important to our owner or pace
500 million for the franchise that we
have a competitive team and we give the
marketplace a chance fans to come watch
this club and be entertained by it and
want to come again and sort of grow some
roots and grow them deep and so the
objective was to be competitive we
drafted a fairly young team there were a
few players that we considered you know
that we you know if we didn't do well we
could we could move with the deadline
but for the most part we drafted young
players that could be here for a while
and and grow with us and and and develop
with us and then the other objective was
to get surplus graphics together
accumulate as many as we could so that
we could also draft our way to success
so and I I think we accomplished both
goals it seems pretty darn competitive
and we have a lot of Draft X when did
you know this season that you might have
something a little better than just a
competitive team hard to say Chris there
were certain times throughout the season
you know we started real well that lots
of teams can do that and we had a real
good run in December
you know as a manager I'm not sure you
let your self think that way that this
is a real good team visit my fingers
were crossed all year hoping that we
didn't turn to dust in the following
week when we got to the deadline that
was the point where we had to say okay
we are we're all in and and we're going
to try to add to this team to make it
better or you know do we go in the other
direction well we sure didn't want to
dismantle anything after the way the
team has played so we added some players
to make us deeper and stronger and I
guess at that point when we're all in
we're gonna go for it
you know the NHL has has thrived in
non-conventional hockey markets before
Vegas is by as unconventional as you get
before you became associated and working
for this team when the idea of Vegas
came up as an HL market what did you
think I was kind of intrigued by it and
and excited about it because I didn't
have a job I had another motivation and
I was I was hoping that you know maybe
I'd get a second chance at least get a
chance to interview for a job in Vegas I
didn't know a whole lot about Vegas
other than what I've seen on this trip I
think when you live and work here it
becomes the opposite of what you
whatever you thought of Vegas it's it's
a it's a real easy place to live it's
easy to get around it's quiet we have
these real beautiful suburbs that we
live in we all live in most of us live
in Summerland great schools and churches
and parks and restaurants and kids
sports and everything else it's like any
other American city it's it's but it has
a nice small-town feel to what the
people are wonderful and but the support
here has been incredible so again I
didn't know what I was getting into but
once I got here it's sort of that used
to it and then you know we have this
fabulous arena right on the strip it's
like dropping you know I never go right
into Madison school
garden into Times Square it's perfect we
have a great practice facility as I said
it's easy to get around easy to get to
the airport great fan base no state tax
I thought geez it's the state income tax
it it's if we do our jobs here we can
win and you know I think the jobs have
done pretty well and we put a good team
on the ice and we've got a chance you
guys are kind of like the sports guinea
pig in some ways I think a lot of the
the major sports like the NFL is on the
way but the NBA has been intrigued by
Vegas for years maybe baseball can get
in the mix did it feel like
like people were watching you and to see
how this team and and and this market
worked out together I imagine they were
I don't know that I really felt that our
experience that you know there were some
naysayers obviously early on but I think
when you get here you realize that this
town was really craving a major league
sports team and you know sometimes
sports teams can give certain cities an
identity you know Las Vegas is a
worldwide brand as a gaming and an
entertainment capital of the world I
guess but it now has another identity
that's becoming a very very good sports
town and so the support that we've been
overcapacity and every single game that
we played we you know our practices are
packed they're open to the public we
have thousands of people here when we're
leading to go away to play a playoff
game that have a little parade horses
we're leading it's really a remarkable
place and and and that the support has
just been beyond our wildest
expectations
how many celebrity ticket requests do
you have for the Conference Finals I
wouldn't know that
but we've certainly all year long been
overwhelmed with ticket requests and you
know I was told by the realtor when we
were moving in here make sure you have
extra bedrooms because everyone wants to
come to Vizio when you live in Vegas
and the realtor was right the neat thing
is I had lots of friends and family and
people haven't seen in many years want
to come out and I think everyone in our
organization has experienced that it's
been kind of a neat year that way I mean
you get like the cast of Cirque de
Soleil saying you know we need like 50
or like a random Tuesday well we
certainly have great relationships with
these organizations and we go to see
their shows a lot they come to the games
a lot these performed between periods
here those nights are really really
special when circus on the ice doing
what they do between periods so it's
it's been a you know it's just a neat
place to live and work because of all
that it has to offer you know there's a
list entertainment everywhere you look
and it's if you want it it's there yeah
no question about that well George
congratulations on all the success and
more to come with the Western Conference
final scheduled start good luck in now
thanks for joining me here on the show
my pleasure thank you very much well as
George McVie the general manager of the
Las Vegas Golden Knights for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]